字幕: Hiroko Kawano
校正: Noriaki Ohta
はい こんにちは wasabiです
みなさんに突然ですが 質問します
みなさんは今 —
「なんでも出来る なんでもしていいよ」
と言われたら
一番 何がしたいですか？
こんな突拍子もない質問を
いきなりされても
ぱっと思い浮かばないかもしれません
もしくは そろそろ眠くなってきてて
今 「寝たい」と即答した人が
いるかも知れないんですが
ちょっとそれはもう少し我慢してもらえたら
嬉しいなと思います
何が言いたいかというと
今 こう聞かれて
ぱっと思い浮かばなかった方
自分のできることとか
したいことっていうのを
もしかしたら 夢っていう 高いレベルで
考えたかもしれないんですが
それを 自分の欲っていう
もう少し身近なレベルに落とし込んで
考えてみるとどうでしょう？
たとえば
「もっと美味しいものが食べたい」とか
「もっといっぱい寝たい」とか
「もう少し違う仕事してみたいな」とか
「もっと休みが欲しい」
「もっと旅行に行きたい」とか
色々出てくるんじゃないでしょうか？
こんな欲くらい
誰だってあると思うのですが
案外この欲に
素直に従っている人って
そんなに多くないのではないかなと
思っています
世の中は本来自由で
いろんな考え方が存在します
私たちの頭の中も同様です
何を考えたっていい —
何を欲したっていいわけです
この欲に従っている人は
そんなに多くないと思っています
でも私は 自分の欲に素直になりたい
こういう枠から外れてみて
その先の人生に
どんな景色が見えるのか？
それを見てみたい
そう思いました
だから私は 怖かったんですが
一歩を踏み出してみることにしました
今日は 実際私が何をしたのか
それについてお話ししたいと思います
まず 私は 大学を卒業した後に
就職活動をしませんでした
なぜなら 日本の就職活動には
おかしなところがいっぱいあると
思っていたからです
たとえば
学業を妨げるような早い時期からの募集
自己分析をして他人と差別化を図る中
結局 最終的には
みんなと同じような格好 —
同じような立ち居振る舞いで
面接に向かう学生たち
そして それを後押しするかのような
社会的なプレッシャー
こういうものです
こういうものを みんな
心の中ではどこかおかしいと
思っているはずなのに
なぜか 従来のやり方に従っています
それは なぜだと思いますか？
答えは簡単です
今までずっと
レールが準備されてきたからです
でも レールといわれても
ピンとこないかもしれません
私も実際そうでした
実際 私が高校生くらいのときは
まさか それまでの自分の人生が
レールの上に乗っかっているだなんて
考えたこともありませんでした
なぜかというと それまでは
自分の人生のこの先が
実は準備されていないんだということを
知らなかったからです
どういうことかというと
人は 今自分がいる場所から
一歩外れて —
レールから外れて見ないと
自分がレールの上にいるのかどうか
さえもわからないんです
日本の社会システムは
幼稚園 小学校 中学校 高校
そして大学 就職という
途切れない 間のあかないシステムに
なっていると思います
そして 大多数の人が
大体 この同じルートをたどります
考えてみれば 私たち日本人の多くは
一回立ち止まって
何が好きなのか
自分は何をしたいのかというのを
考えなくてもいいシステムの
中にあると思います
そして 私が
このことに気づいたのは
就職活動をするかしないかを迫られた
大学４年生のときでした
私は思いました
ああ ここからは自分で自分の人生
決めて行かなきゃいけないんだ
私はとても悩みました
海外でフリーランサーになりたい
という思いはあったのですが
今までずっと こんな風にして
何かの集団に所属してきていたので
学生でもない
社会人でもない
肩書きが使えない
ただの人になるのは
一体どういうことなのか
全く想像がつきませんでした
それを考えただけで
自分のなかのアイデンティティが
大きく揺らぐような
危機感を覚えたことも事実です
でも 私には
一つだけ譲れない夢というか
欲がありました
それは ヨーロッパに住み
自分の好きなことで働くという
夢というか欲です
私はこの自分の
小さい欲望をかなえるためには
一体 どうしたらいいのかを
考えました
最初は日本の会社に就職して
経験を積んでから海外に行くということも
考えたんですが
それは自分の欲に反していることでした
なぜかというと 私は
すぐに行きたかったんです
もちろん 会社に入れば
経済的にも そして 精神的にも
安心感が得られるかもしれません
でも 最初は自分のやりたいことを
好き勝手に選べないかもしれないですし
やりたくもない仕事を経験のためといって
こなさないといけないかもしれません
第一 時間がかかります
だから私は もちろん怖かったんですが
一歩を踏み出してみみることにしたんです
でも 最初は
海外に渡って 新卒で
フリーランサーになるという考えは
いろんな人に否定されました
「いきなり海外で 経験なしで
新卒でフリーランサーなんて
難しいでしょ」
とか
「一旦 就職しないと社会人としてのマナーが
身につかないよ」 とか
一番多かったのは
「フリーランサーっていうのは 普通
就職してからなるものなんだよ」
という アドバイスでした
私はこう言われて
本当に心細くなってしまいました
周りに 同じような経験をしている人も
いなければ
この選択を応援してくれる人にも
なかなか出会えなかったからです
でも私は
一つだけ分かっていたことがあります
それは こうした言葉を
かけてきた人たちは誰一人として
海外に渡って新卒で
フリーランサーになったことがなかったんです
当たり前ですが 人は
自分が経験していないことについては
語れません
だから私は こうした言葉を
一旦無視してみることにしたんです
結果として 今は
あのとき無視して本当によかったなと
思っています
こうして今 私は
海外でフリーランサーとして
翻訳 ブログ ライティングなどの仕事を
自分の好きなだけ
やることができています
自分の人生を自分で構築している感覚が
とってもあります
こんな人生もあるんだなと
今すごく驚いていますし
こんなライフスタイルは
日本を出る前には
全く考えられないことでした
でも 今は
時代の流れも IT化が加速して
こうした自分で決める
ライフスタイルというのを
後押ししてくれるんです
その最もいい例がブログです
[こんなやり方もある!をブログで発信]
私は去年の秋から本格的に
ブログ更新を始めたのですが
ブログの更新を始めたきっかけは
とっても些細なものでした
せっかく 海外に来て
こうして 人と違う経験をしている
自分だからこそ
何か語れるものがあるんじゃないか？
そう思って
自分が海外で新卒で
フリーランサーになった経緯や
海外で見える多様なライフスタイル
の可能性を
ブログでシェアしてみることにしたんです
すると ある日
私が書いたこの記事
この記事がフェイスブックやツイッター
などのSNSを通じて
たくさん方に読まれシェアされました
そのときの私の
ブログの１日の訪問者数は
10人未満という
本当に無名なブログだったんですが
この記事が単体で
大きな反響を呼んで
私だけが感じていたと思っていた
違和感や
別のライフスタイルの可能性に
共感してくれる人が現れたんです
私はとっても嬉しかったですし
インターネットの可能性を
感じた瞬間でもありました
そしてもう一つ
大きな反響を呼んだ記事があります
それは 今欧州で話題となっている
難民問題に関する記事です
日本では 難民というと
生身の人間であることがイメージしにくい —
どこか遠い存在であるかのように
思われているかもしれません
そこで 私は
ドイツにやって来たシリア人の
難民となってしまった友人に
インタビューをし
難民という人が
本当は何を思っているのか？
そしてどんなことを経験して来たのか？という
あまりニュースでは
語られない部分をシェアしたところ
公開直後から50,000［ページ］ビューを超える
大きな反響を戴くことができました
記事は本当に多くの方に読まれ
社会的に影響力のある
著名人やジャーナリストなどにも
シェアしてもらうことができました
私はその時思いました
こんな自分でも世の中の意識を
変えることができるかも知れない
今は 年齢も性別も経験だって関係ない —
ただ 人の心に真っ直ぐ届くものが
書ければ
それがちゃんと人に届く時代に
なったんだなと
自分自身が
こういう経験をしていて感じるのは
この変化の速い時代 —
ひと昔前まで常識だったことなど
いとも簡単に変わってしまう
ということです
ひと昔前であれば
私のような無名な人間が
自分の意見を
発表できるような場所もなければ
それをこんなに多くの方に
読んでもらうなんて
考えられないことでした
でも 今は違います
だからこそ —
誰もが常識に思っていないことこそ —
誰もが疑問に思っていないことこそ —
それが本当に 「自分にとっては
本当なのかどうか」というのを
確かめるクセをつけて下さい
考えることは 人に
より多くの可能性を見せてくれます
そして それを実際に行動に移すことは
人により多くの選択肢を与えてくれる
と思うからです
私は この度合いが増えれば増えるほど
人は自由になるんだと思っています
実際 私がこうしていられるのも
常識という波に負けず
自分で疑問を持ち続け
それを実際に行動に移したからこそだと
思っています
私は今 何でもできるなという
気がしています
そしてみなさんも
何でもできるんです
もっと多くの方に 自分が持っている可能性
というのに気がついて欲しい —
自分が好きなことは何か？
自分がしたいことは何なのか？というのを
素直に心で感じ
それに向かって最短距離で動くんです
たとえそれが
常識外れに見えるとしてでもです
私はその時こそ 人が本当に
自分の手で自分の人生を
切り拓いて行く瞬間
なのではないかと思っています
ありがとうございました
（拍手）